welcome to this video just one guitar
yep that's a no point that I had quite a
bit um but not not for a while so that's
let's play or it's a Catalan that's not
that not so exciting yeah okay a queen's
gambit i would have tried something a
little bit different but ok in the
catalan let's play the clothes catalan
here with this Bishop before check and
so did this gives some more interesting
play for black than some others ok I
mean it's not that it's not super
exciting but ok yeah I think that that
should be quite ok for me now ctek see
takes usually is quite a success for
black that's an interesting interesting
moment I wonder if 27 is good or not
probably it is right it accelerates my
development but after that you might
have a four-night beehive I can go now
that's ok it's ok let's do that a 435 is
not so dangerous so we got Quinn's off
early yeah I think in general I should
be ok here in this position I wonder
especially before an idea just attacking
e2 probably just just the wrong
just the locals mm-hmm I'm steady
rotated about a form okay 495 night
coming to beehive would be a little bit
of an annoyance but I can't I don't
think it's particularly bad hmm on the
other hand what am i doing next it looks
very unexcited but what can you do he's
played a very sound solid opening yep
he's going for this
like to be high
yeah what am i doing about that I was
thinking we should be 7i just a six
doesn't look very active but should be
ok actually and i th you might have ele
form if i go hmm should be 795 and i can
just play something like a five but it's
not that's really not very interesting
what about 95 98 rook c8 bishop c8 yeah
that's probably probably about equal but
it's not not very interesting and a5 is
even less interesting yeah but anyway
and still lasts all night sis Bishop c8
can i play book CA 10 9 8 7 roxy to hmm
you know that might be might be better
have a bit more active okay so i can go
a six now and kick this this night out
okay so what what is that Bishop d8 is
this any good takes takes rook c7 is a
bit of an annoyance so I should probably
do this yeah that's approach with the
king it's 95 a move maybe not but ok i
can probably take it takes d chinks
Bishop c5 yeah that's even it's even
good good for black I mean okay okay for
black so mm-hmm see threatening anything
probably not let's control g5 for Bishop
t8 takes King takes ok so he's really
just she just wants to trade stuff ok
check I guess I simply have nothing
better so I have to have to go with that
maybe hmm maybe I can actually try to do
something on the queenside with this a4
move attack it with Bishop to c6 my king
is a little bit more active that's the
only the thing that I have going in my
favor my King might be able to to join
join on the queenside
she going 85 I don't know let's start
with that maybe this and then b5 u 3 p-5
and takes Bishop takes they have chances
to get a decent endgame out of that if
he goes Bishop everyone I think I have a
slight edge maybe after that very slide
one I ok so hmm but after cheeks Bishop
cheeks I don't mind that I take on a
form take on a four and Bishop to an ID
be a it is this then he has to go a five
I go and then f6 and Bishop before then
it's slightly better really let's do
that it's not the very natural move but
it is it ok and now this one try to make
a five weakness yeah that's it sits a
little something my king is near that
porn check you think it's more weakness
than than a strength ok f6 I have to
move my king time morning now King up to
c6 be for King b5 and that's it for the
pawn the question is does he have a
counter play Knight f4 he has now so
let's go here prevent night f form I can
just take it off here and King be 585
for the pawn that that is like pressing
water out of stone but sometimes
sometimes you manage to do that
right over to a five
what is the best thing this is the best
right fixing on dark squares but still
giving me opportunities to enter the
position i wonder if i should actually
okay it's actually not not at all easy
to win this may be here for g5g five
maybe i don't have time to really
calculate this till the end at this two
weaknesses now you can check a for fe
chicks be fine I've got got the wrong
bishop in check it's mostly about check
each a quickly now white forfeits on
time was lucky actually King III so it's
a stalemate yeah I was just
instinctively not taking it i don't know
i didn't see that really that is it
stalemate yeah that was as i said
pressing water out of stone but
sometimes well you have to play the hand
that you dealt and simply and it didn't
have anything great but i think it was
it was okay all the time equal ish 9p
590 m th form yeah thought you would
probably just take him but rook takes
them I mean Bishop takes as a tad
passive not sure I don't I don't think
it's anything great for white ahi it
still doesn't have this Bishop in play I
would have played rook c8 night is
heaven looks it too wet looked a bit
more active
no but maybe this is probably what you
should have done after that don't i
don't think i have got anything to fear
just equal ish king of 80 AD it's a nice
195 I missed that move tactic I really
wasn't looking for tactics IAM
interesting chat activates the night
here enormously and gets the C file that
would have been quite interesting this
Bishop is also not having many squares
interesting yeah I didn't see that I was
really just focused on improving the
position slowly yeah he said to our
plate and as I said things I'm not so
sure about a chat what happened to him I
mean I didn't didn't do much but somehow
somehow he gave me some opportunities ya
hear a 5 jam here i am a little bit
better than five pawn but the compass
sir ok now the comp goes down 0.4 check
to divide it to the capture yeah i
really wonder i thought about about here
I didn't see how he keeps the porn long
run will be difficult and now it's 0.7
yet it's probably a step-by-step process
even though it's not even clear if I'm
winning him what is the engine giving
the engine wants to do this no chief or
just wants to play this position and
gives equal hmm interesting yeah maybe
it is equal now equals may be wrong the
wrong word but I mean black hand can try
but
maybe I don't have a way forward the
Nigeria is really just it's just there
to protect before I cannot regroup that
this is what the engine is giving can I
not just play you five now I Bishop hear
things like that it doesn't lead to much
yeah it's possible it's really possible
that this was yeah now what now the
difference is my night I get the pawn
but I also get my night activated of
course it's um it's difficult to to play
okay here here I haven't improved my 97
five this is probably even better it
wins one of those pawns but i am not
sure i think does this end game should
be it should be too bad with g5 coming
I'm getting an additional I'm giving him
an additional weakness cm yeah this is
this is not helping if why it stays
can I zoosk wrong him it's not so easy
the engine wants to do this and f5 that
is just a draw I mean very obviously it
raw why it stays here and white stays
here and it's just that the engine
doesn't understand it of course gives
minus one point three this is just
typical engine miss evaluation and not
understanding the fortress yeah for
human it's very obvious that this is a
draw but the engine is just not yet
getting at um so that's not winning I
have to do it somehow differently let's
same yeah but really if i go here
specially you won't be form now that's a
drawn i think it's a draw this position
if white stays yeah that makes night
takes a five probably a real mistake
this is much better okay so well thanks
for watching